[Musica]
[Applauso]
non riesco a immaginare una vita senza
storie riesco a immaginare una vita
senza tv a casa nostra è arrivata quando
avevo 17 anni prima c'era solamente a
sprazzi riesco a immaginare una vita
senza radio per fortuna c'erano i dischi
di papà albinoni de andrè e gli enti li
mani su questi ultimi filo filippo timi
ha avuto modo di riderci parecchio sopra
perché io in effetti mi diceva sempre
che dovevo smetterla di vestirmi come
mentili mano ed era vero ma questa è
un'altra storia
riesco a immaginarmi una vita senza
senza macchine senza temporali ma non
riesco a immaginare una vita senza
storie a casa nostra c'è le raccontava
papa a cena
le inventava sul momento story espresse
dire pero adesso mamma invece ci faceva
fare i pupazzi di cartapesta e poi le
storie che dovevamo animare noi ma
eravamo abbastanza allenati perché
quelle rare volte che c'era la
televisione passava un film di paura
guai se lo vedevamo tutto non avveniva
sempre interrotto prima e quindi il
resto ce lo dovevamo inventare me ne
ricordo uno che noi chiamavamo la donna
cicatrizzata
chissà quale fosse poi il titolo vero
nessuno di noi l'ha mai saputo perché ad
un certo punto compariva questa signora
in camicia da notte bianca con una
grande cicatrice sulla faccia e faceva
molta paura anche se non l'avevamo visto
perché quella volta mamma l'aveva spento
quasi subito però noi cielo raccontavamo
lo stesso
c'era una volta il ragionier bianchi di
varese questo è uno dei primi inizi di
storia che mi ricordo allora erogene
bianchi era un signore che girava per
tutta italia non faceva il
rappresentante di commercio e la
domenica sera tornava a casa e il lunedì
mattina già ripartiva ma prima che
ripartisse la figlia gli diceva papà mi
raccomando misero la storia
e allora lui ogni sera
un punto ovunque si trovasse chiamava al
telefono varese e raccontava una storia
la sua bambina
ovviamente queste sono le favole al
telefono di gianni rodari
io leggevo sempre mi piaceva tanto mi
riempivano i pomeriggi d'estate
se me lo ricordano e leggevo seduta sul
balcone di casa nostra di via gervasoni
nell'edizione futurista quella con i
disegni di bruno munari e c'era alice
cascherina che cascava sempre
dappertutto non so se vi ricordate
c'erano i tre fratelli di barletta che
alla fine saranno mangiati la strada
perché avevano scoperto che era di
cioccolata poi c'era lo stand perino lo
stack a panni del paese con la s
maiuscola s davanti e poi c'era una
delle mie preferite giacomo di cristallo
una volta in una città lontana venne al
mondo un bambino trasparente attraverso
le sue membra si poteva vedere come
attraverso l'aria e l'acqua era fatto di
carne da un sano sembrava di vetro se
casca la terra però non si rompe va in
pezzi no no no tutt'altro gli compariva
un bernoccolo trasparente sulla fronte
si poteva vedere il suo cuore batte si
potevano vedere i suoi pensieri guizzare
come pesci colorati nella loro vasca una
volta per sbaglio dice una bugia è
subito comparve come una palla di fuoco
dietro la sua fronte di sa la verità e
la palla di fuoco scomparve non disse
più c'è poi un'altra volta un amico gli
rivelò un segreto e lui subito tutti
potevano vedere come una palla nera che
rotolava dentro il suo petto senza pace
e il segreto non fu più tale sì insomma
questo bambino crebbe diventò un
giovanotto poi un uomo è però ancora si
potevano leggere i suoi pensieri anche
se non apriva bocca si indovinava la
risposta solo li faceva una domanda si
chiamava giacomo ma tutti lo chiamavano
giacomo di cristallo e gli volevano bene
per la sua lealtà e vicino a lui
diventavano tutti i più gentili
però poi un giorno andò al governo un
dittatore feroce inizia un periodo di
prepotenze violenze e miseria per il
popolo allora siccome chi parlava poi
sparire
lasciare traccia chi si ribellava veniva
fucilato cosa succedeva che tutta la
gente taceva e subiva per timore delle
conseguenze no ma giacomo non poteva
tacere perché anche se non parlava anche
se non apriva bocca i suoi pensieri
parlavano per lui e quindi la gente che
passava poteva leggere i suoi pensieri
di sdegno e di condanna adempiranno per
quello che stava facendo il tiranno e
poi se mi ripetevano tra di loro e cosa
succedeva che prendevano coraggio allora
il tiranno niente fece arrestare giacomo
di cristallo lo gettò in una prigione
buia ma successa una cosa incredibile
che le mura della sua cella diventano
trasparenti e anche le mura del carcere
e anche le mura esterne
allora la gente passava e vedevano
stesso giacomo di cristallo seduto sul
suo sgabello e continua a leggere i suoi
pensieri e poi di notte la prigione
spandeva una grande luce tutta intorno
il tiranno che savona il suo palazzo
anche se tira ma le tende non riusciva a
dormire lo stesso giacomo di cristallo
anche se in catene era più forte di lui
perché la verità è più forte di
qualsiasi cosa più luminosa del giorno
più terribile di un uragano
ecco io leggevo le favole al telefono di
gianni rodari e mi sembrava di imparare
qualcosa sulla vita lì sembrava meglio
di dare forma significato
mi sembra ridare una faccia a quelle
parole di quelle parole astratte che ti
dicevo nei grandi no per cui la parola
verità per me coincideva con giacomo di
cristallo affermare di che bisogna
sempre dire la verità significava fare
la rivoluzione insieme a lui
ecco il potere formativo delle storie ma
non mi piacevano soltanto le storie
queste qua di immaginazione simboliche
no no mi piacevano
no mi piacevano tanto storia
mi piaceva tantissimo le storie vere e
allora da piccola chiedevo sempre un po
tutti di raccontarmi né una mano non
volevo che me la raccontasse tutta
infiocchettata tall citano io la volevo
dritto per dritto in faccia così come
era successo e mi ricordo che una volta
la mia maestra di catechismo per
spiegarci una parabola sulla perdita ci
aveva raccontato che quando era morto
suo padre lei non si dava pace che il
mondo continua se come se niente fosse
cioè diceva ma com'è possibile
guardava fuori dalla finestra e diceva
ma com'è possibile che gli autobus
passino
ma come è possibile che le macchine si
muovono e tutto si dovrebbe fermare e mi
era piaciuto quel pezzetto di racconto
che ci aveva fatto mi era piaciuto più
delle altre cose che stavamo leggendo
perché era suo perché era vero perché
anche se non avevo ancora mai provato io
lo avrei riconosciuto per sentire lì poi
dopo molti anni ho visto un notevole
ritardo devo dire quel film bellissimo
quattro matrimoni e un funerale so se
l'avete visto spero e ad un certo punto
uno dei protagonisti
piange la scomparsa del suo compagno e
recita una poesia di oden fermate gli
orologi
tagliate i fili del telefono e regalate
un osso al cane affinché non abbai
faccio il silenzio il pianoforte
tacciano i ristoranti i tamburi che
avanzi la bara che vengano gli amici
dolenti lasciate che gli aerei
volteggiano nel cielo e scrivano
l'odioso messaggio lui è morto
guarnite di crespo il collo bianco dei
piccioni e fate che il vigile urbano
indossi lunghi guanti neri
lui era il mio nord era il mio sud era
l'oriente e l'occidente
i miei giorni di lavoro i miei giorni di
festa era il mezzo di la mezzanotte la
mia musica le mie parole
credevo che l'amore potesse durare per
sempre ma era un'illusione offuscate
tutte le stelle perché non le vuole più
nessuno
buttate via la luna tirateci il sole
svuotate gli oceani e abbattere gli
alberi perché da questo momento niente
servirà più a niente
era esattamente questo che ci aveva
raccontato ama essere il catechismo
perché perché le storie hanno il potere
di restituire quello che universalmente
sentiamo e che chiamiamo in maniera
astratta sentimenti ma che a dirlo così
semplicemente ci sembra che non basti
soffocano di più le sta attraverso le
storie noi riusciamo ad aderire alle
emozioni che riusciamo a riconoscerle a
comprenderle insomma allora non lo
sapevo ma stavo imparando che non esiste
empatia senza le storie e non esistono
storie senza i luoghi che le
custodiscono io e mia sorella andavamo a
16 anni a dipingere sopra il campo di
girasole sul campo di girasole sopra
sopra la giuggiola la giuggiola era la
casa che mio nonno lillo comprò un
giorno da un contadino mentre i miei
genitori ancora fidanzati stavano
passeggiando sul monte conero allora
loro e disse ragazzi l'ho presa era il
era il periodo del boom economico il suo
negozio di vernici e cartina per carte
da parati andava benissimo
ecco mi piaceva tanto quella casa perché
stava dentro un monte ma sarà anche
sopra il mare
ogni estate una famiglia di tedeschi si
univa alla nostra è anche una famiglia
di austriaci che però non abitava lì con
noi sarà in un'altra casa però di giorno
stavamo tutti insieme e la sera
camminavamo cantando per riaccompagnarli
tutti insieme ognuno una canzone diversa
all'unisono per fare più rumore coprire
la paura poi invece di giorno
scenderanno al mare passando per
l'incrocio dove c'era il fico e le
ragazze tedesche che erano un pochino
più grandi di noi stavano a seno nudo e
mi mai pasquale che erano i proprietari
del baretto scalcinato dove andavamo a
prendere le chiassose lanciano le tasse
i nudisti che invece quando rimanevamo a
casa cioè noi scendevamo al mare
giocavamo alla vita e io avevo un bar
con un tavolino e due seggiole e
sgabelli e le bottigliette in miniatura
di liquore che mi portava mio papà dai
viaggi era un bar per innamorati il mio
c'era solo due seggiole
poi c'era il venditore di pipe scavate
minuziosamente a mio fratello
dentro le pigne e poi c'era il
gioielliere che tagliava ad anelli le
canne di bambù e ci incastona va sopra
dei frammenti di bottiglia di vari
colori levigate dal mare e non ci
mancava niente perché avevamo anche il
disoccupato golfi un bambino lentissimo
che ci metteva il doppio di noi a
mangiare quindi toccava sempre
aspettarlo per ricominciare a giocare in
giardino alla giunge la c'era un gelso
con una grande chioma
e sotto a questa grande chioma ci
eravamo tutti insieme la sera è l'anno
che è mancato mio padre il jazz è
ammalato e dopo pochi mesi è morto io
neanche sapevo che gli alberi si
ammalassero pensavo che fossero eterni e
quando mia madre ha deciso di vendere la
giuggiola sono stata molto arrabbiata
con lei perché mi sembrava che
portandoci via quel posto ci avrebbe
portato via anche le storie di quelle
stati nella nostra famiglia
le storie sono la quarta dimensione
della realtà danno volume al nostro
sentire allora mi sono sempre piaciute
le materie scientifiche sempre perché ti
spiegano sala scienzati spiega un sacco
di cose ti dice come siamo fatti come
funzioniamo sua ti dà anche un po di
pace saperlo ogni tanto sentirsi sulla
mappa sicura ci dice che noi esseri
viventi siamo materia organica che la
materia organica dentro contiene il
carbonio che attraverso il carbonio
possiamo risalire addirittura all'epoca
di un tronco anche se di migliaia e
migliaia di anni fa ci sia un sacco di
cose però in nessun libro di chimica
fisica biologia si parla del bisogno che
abbiamo che la realtà sia bagnata cioè
inondata da un sentire che ci travolge
tutti che ci collega da una parte
all'altra del pianeta a noi esseri umani
e ci fa risuonare come un'unica voce
non so se vi ricordate la novella di
pirandello ciaula scopre la luna quando
quando ciaula risale dopo aver passato
l'ennesima giornata in miniera inizia a
risalire verso l'uscita piegato in
avanti sotto il peso del carico che
porta sulle spalle così pesanti che
quasi tocca con la testa lo scalino che
gli sta davanti esce
la luna quella è un'esperienza
disarmante
perché lui sapeva che c'era la luna lo
sapeva ma come tante cose si sanno ma
cui non si è mai dato importanza
cosa gli poteva importare a ciaula che
in cielo ci fosse la luna
ora ora soltanto così sbucato dal ventre
della terra egli la scopriva grande
placida come in un fresco luminoso
oceano di silenzio gli stava di faccia
la luna è statico cade a sedere sul suo
carico davanti alla buca
eccola eccola là eccola la la luna c'era
la luna e ciaula si mise a piangere
senza saperlo senza volerlo dal gran
conforto dalla grande dolcezza che
sentiva nell'aver la scoperta la mentre
la saliva per il cielo la luna
col suo ampio velo di luce ignara dei
monti dei piani per valle che rischiara
ma ignara di lui che pure per lei non
aveva più paura né si sentiva più stanco
nella notte ora piena nel suo stupore
io non sono più riuscito a dimenticarla
la sensazione di questo ragazzino col
mani nere che esce dalla buca e scopre
la luna
mi ricordo che mi sembrava con me di
essere lui e anche se io non c'entravo
niente con lui perché chiaramente non
era un minatore sicilia vano alpha beta
mi trovavo lì davanti all'antologia di
italiano totalmente attraversata da
quelle emozioni di quel ragazzino che
stava da un'altra parte non è proposto
in un altro tempo ma che io sentivo
completamente per me in quel momento
c'erano solo gli occhi di ciaula dentro
la mia testa che piangevano come i miei
oppure attraverso i miei o viceversa non
lo so
la dignità dei sentimenti è una cosa che
appartiene a tutti ed è intoccabile
poi all'università mi sono iscritta
6 matematiche fisiche naturali e solo
che dopo un anno è successo qualcosa che
mi ha evidentemente portato dall altra
parte
studiamo chimica organica e lei bordini
bianchi del libro di chimica li riempiva
tutti questi bordini con disegni poesie
insomma il periodo che scrivevo cose
tipo ai ridotto i miei polmoni come due
foglie secche a forza di selezionare
l'aria da respirare non è rimasta
neppure un panno ai sedotto i miei
ormoni con un bicchiere di [ __ ] siamo
due calabroni e sforzarci addossano
finito per perdere l'udito con quel tuo
ronzio fisso mi è rimasta soltanto una
mano e ci voglio andare lontano da te e
dopo che avevo finito i bordini bianchi
nobel del libro di chimica chiaramente
dovevo fare qualcosa perché insomma
questa roba continuava ribollivano mi
sono iscritto al corso di teatro 26 la
settimana solo che a mezzanotte quando
tu erano passate già quattro ore tutti
erano stanchi ok buonanotte ciao andiamo
a casa
io invece volevo continuare e allora mi
hanno suggerito vivamente di provare a
entrare un corso intensivo che c'era
pontedera bisognava fare un colloquio
però se poi ti prendevano ti pagavano
pure per farlo quindi sono andata a fare
il colloquio di nascosto da mia madre
perché perché dovevo preoccuparla 70 poi
metti non mi prendevano infatti era una
presa prima dei non presi poi però il
giorno prima che iniziasse il corso uno
dei paesi si è ritirato
quindi a quel punto toccava dirglielo e
anche in fretta però siccome non avevo
proprio il coraggio non mi veniva
proprio non riusciva la voce di
dirglielo
ho scritto una lettera e gli ero
consegnata di persona chiedendole se
poteva leggerla davanti a me l'ha letta
e quando ho finito di leggerlo ma quando
parte mi fa adesso vengo con te e così
siamo partite tutte e due
siamo andate a pontedera e quella notte
a pontedera non abbiamo dormito molto né
io né lei perché lei mi continuava a
dire luce ma sei sicura così sicura che
questa sia la strada
ma cosa ci fai col teatro
lucia ma sei sicura luce ma pensa ci sia
ancora il tempo si però dormiamo perché
il teatro per me è un posto che ha dato
spazio a una voce che non sapeva nemmeno
di avere e che volesse uscire perché
ognuno di noi o dentro delle zone che
vogliono uscire non bisogna sentire
perché altrimenti si comprimono e ti
deformano la faccia io voglio avere una
faccia dritta che per sapere quello che
ho dentro perché tutti gli esseri
animali vegetali anche i funghi che non
sono né animali né vegetali non so se lo
sapete sono possibili cioè in natura non
esiste quello diverso quello strano
quanto si stava non esiste non c'è ma
hanno bisogno tutti gli esseri di vivere
e crescere in un posto giusto adatta
loro in questo posto giusto ciascuno di
noi adatto a ciascuno di noi e crescere
svilupparsi si chiama nicchia ecologica
io a pontedera avevo trovato la mia
nicchia ecologica e poi ci sono le
storie rubate cioè un mio amico attore
scrittore regista amava molto ascoltare
le storie mi racconti che gli facevo
quando gli raccontavo di cosa pensavo
quando ero piccola di quei giorni come
s'era sentita mia zia quel giorno che
noi insomma stava per morire per fatto
che avevo una teoria sui giorni della
settimana del fatto che soffrisse di
nostalgia già sei anni gli piaceva
perché diceva magari mi possono servire
di ispirazione per qualcosa che sto
scrivendo e io iniziavo a sentire un
senso di possesso verso quelle cose
verso le mie storie aromi e nessuno
voleva toccare poi una mia amica mi ha
detto ma cosa fa e lucia ma guarda che
nei rapporti di famiglia e questo lo è
si dà e basta non si fanno conti non si
trattiene sfida e basta allora ho tolto
questo senso di possesso e ho fatto così
ed è successa una cosa incredibile
cioè lui filippo mi ha chiamato e mi ha
detto senti lucia ma avevano proposto un
monologo ma invece ho deciso di fare uno
spettacolo con due protagonisti
di un pensatore che farà tre fratelli
gemelli
ho pensato che voglio mettere nei testi
dei nostri personaggi anche dei pezzetti
delle tue storie
la storia appunto si chiamava favola ed
è diventato uno spettacolo che ha girato
per quattro anni più di 300 repliche
tutto esaurito ogni sera è poi diventato
un film ea forza di abitare le nostre
storie sera dopo sera giorno dopo giorno
è successa con una magia cioè quei due
personaggi dove dentro c'ero anch'io da
piccola
c'era la carta da parati marrone con le
arance rosse tutte in fila della mia
cucina c'erano tutti i pensieri e
l'immaginario di una bambina
inconsolabile che soffriva di nostalgia
sono diventati altro da noi qualcosa che
si ci conteneva ma che nello stesso
tempo ci sorpassava sono diventati
personaggi familiari di cinema nonché
non più solo noi perché le storie sequel
esperienza mi ha insegnato che le storie
nel momento in cui noi le raccontiamo
non sono più solo nostre sono anche di
chi le ascolta le storie assottigliano
la distanza tra gli esseri umani si le
storie ci conducono nel tempo mescolando
passato e presente ci trascinano giù
nella cascata di continui salti genetici
che ci rendono unici e ci collegano ci
scambiano ci uniscono le storie fanno
vibrare le nostre anime
attraverso il tempo e lo spazio ci
abitano ci dicono ci raccontano ci fanno
dire per sempre
caccia
[Applauso]